a
[Música]
hoy es el día de martin luther quien en
eeuu que hace honor a la activista
social que luchó por los derechos de los
afroamericanos y en la ciudad habrá
caravanas desfiles y otros eventos las
autoridades están preocupadas porque
precisamente en esos eventos se pueden
presentar enfrentamientos entre
activistas afroamericanos y
simpatizantes de donald trump el centro
de washington está completamente cerrado
militarizado por guardia nacional son
más de 25 mil hombres de la guardia
nacional hay policía metropolitana hay
policía del capitolio fbi servicios
secretos en varios frentes de la fuerza
pública congregados en la capital para
evitar la violencia y es que en redes
sociales simpatizantes de trump han
convocado el 20 de enero día de la
posesión de joe biden y kamala harris a
una marcha llamada milicia maga marcha
una marcha de milicia de simpatizantes
de trump que quieren volver a tomarse la
ciudad y generar violencia nuevamente en
washington
[Música]
en california en la capital de este
estado en sacramento donde está el
capitolio este fin de semana se
desplegaron importantes unidades de la
policía para proteger este edificio ya
que al igual que el resto de los 50
estados estaban en alerta por posibles
posibles protestas violentas de después
de las llamadas a la insurrección de
varios grupos de extrema derecha entre
ellos los llamados boogaloo voices o si
este fin de semana al menos aquí en
california y en el resto de los estados
del oeste no ha habido ninguna protesta
no se ha visto a ninguno de estos grupos
en torno a estos capitolios eso sí
excepto el estado de texas donde un
pequeño grupo bastante reducido sí que
se congregó en torno al capitolio aunque
no hubo ninguna violencia ninguna
tensión grave con la policía sin embargo
a pesar de que este fin de semana si ha
transcurrido relativamente tranquilo la
policía se mantiene en alerta máxima
también en los 50 estados sobre todo
también en torno al capitolio ya que se
prevé que haya más protestas violentas a
medida que avance
hasta el miércoles que será la toma de
poder de joe biden
[Música]
semana crucial también en florida el
estado que en las pasadas elecciones
certificó su apoyo mayoritario a donald
trump y al partido republicano aquí ha
habido un profundo malestar
especialmente en las comunidades
hispanas como la cubana y la venezolana
que respaldaron la reelección del
presidente saliente y adoptaron algunos
discursos de su administración como que
los comicios fueron fraudulentos sin
presentar pruebas y después de que
varias cortes desestimaran los recursos
parece que el estado del sol se va a
convertir en el próximo hogar de la aún
familia presidencial fuentes de la casa
blanca han confirmado que donald trump
llegar a florida el próximo miércoles
sobre las 11 de la mañana justo una hora
antes de que se cumpla oficialmente su
mandato como presidente llegará al
aeropuerto de west palm beach y se
trasladará a su residencia de mar a lago
un lugar que se ha convertido en lo que
algunos han llamado la casa blanca de
verano está por ver si finalmente se
quedará a vivir aquí porque parece que
habría firmado un contrato con las
autoridades locales señalando que no
fijaría su residencia permanente en el
club privado
[Música]